The Spectator magazine combines incisive
political analysis with books and arts
reviews of unrivaled Authority try a
month in print and online for free and
for a limited time only get a free
wireless phone charger go to WWE taco UK
forward slash charger to start today
hello and welcome to this episode of
audio reads this week we hear from
Douglas Murray professor Paul Dolan and
Andrew Watts first up is Douglas Murray
on what Labour's new attack line should
be now that the Tories had become the
party of the NHS I wonder what the
Labour Party will use as its scare
slogan at the next election after all
the usual one of insert number weeks
days minutes to save the NHS may not
work next time not that it worked every
time before but it has long been the
favourite attack line of a British left
that likes to portray the Conservative
Party as so ravenously right-wing but
whenever it comes to power it wastes not
a moment in dismantling Ackley's
post-war creation and yet although the
Conservative Party has been in power
fairly often since 1945 not once has it
managed to dismantle privatize or
otherwise sell-off the NHS its tendency
rather has been to increase spending
ring-fence spending and more if the
masterplan remained the same then the
party has been uniquely inept at its
implementation and while believable it
seems more likely that the Conservative
Party long ago made its peace with the
welfare state and that the Labour Party
has acted with a degree of disingenuine
T at recent general elections for shame
the reason why the line may particularly
not work next time is not just that Matt
Hancock will not appear in public
without his rainbow badge rather it will
be because by 2024 it will have become
plain that in 2020 a Conservative
government ran up one of the biggest
bills in history in order to save the
NHS not from collapse but from the
indignities and worse that so visibly
affected parts of the Italian Health
Service at the beginning of the coffered
pandemic
three things at least have become plain
over recent weeks the first is that if
the decision to go into this lockdown
was taken in order to avert Italian like
scenes in our hospitals then that has
been achieved thanks to the success of
the lockdown the Nightingale hospitals
have joined the UK workforce in furlough
the second thing that has become plain
is that the virus is both worse than
some people on the right spent the early
part of the crisis pretending and at the
same time not as bad as we first feared
there is no point in being blase about
this but this fact can be noted in at
least two ways that the mortality
figures do not reach the extreme ends of
the earliest projections whatever the
containment policies of the country in
question and that people who have got
the virus have been pulling through it
even without hospitalization better than
was feared at the outset which brings me
to the third thing that has now become
clear that is the vast cost of this
ducking exercise with almost half the
workforce now effectively in the employ
of the state world war two sized bill
for tackling virus was just one of the
headlines that went wafting by last week
yet the point of running up this amount
of debt in the 1940s was not just that
the threat was existential but that we
did not expect such expenditure of blood
and treasure to be demanded again can
anyone say the same with the virus
China has gifted the world at least
three such gifts in the past decade or
so must we run up a world war 2 sized
debt every time China infects us the
meeting place of the declining medical
threat and the increasing economic
threat points to one inexorable fact
which is that this state of suspended
animation and consequences cannot go on
if the virus is not as bad as the bonds
at Imperial College first expected that
it cannot justify the ongoing
containment of the population at least
not all of it it is true that the virus
seems to have plenty of anomalies we
still don't understand
but while the elderly and those with
underlying health conditions do seem to
be at risk the young and healthy do not
and while the vulnerable must continue
to be protected what is not sustainable
is for a workforce at almost zero risk
to be kept in its rented accommodation
and further a misery 'td due to it I can
already see the books they will write
these Millennials and younger the
Boomers last act they will call it a
generation they were already accusing of
having accumulated all the wealth will
be said as their last act to have force
the majority of the younger population
not just into poverty but into chastity
in order to keep a tiny section of the
boomer party going a little while longer
a future Margaret Atwood will have a
great time collecting royalties of this
as with our current Margaret Atwood
I'm not certain it's as straightforward
as that what I do know is that a way out
of the current predicament becomes an
economic necessity long before our world
becomes risk-free
it will start with those people willing
to take the small risk of returning to
work and while the poorer will most
likely be forced into taking more risks
I expect that as things drag on more and
more people are going to accept that
just as there are many elements of risk
in our lives so coverage is one of them
if not then it seems as though we are in
one of those moments of history where
what you took to be the main event turns
out to be the prelude this tussle is
going on in all of us at present
but as the health risks become clearer
so do the economic ones and while we
have a considerable chance of ducking
the first no one has any chance of
ducking the second we have given the
Health Service an awful lot throughout
its history never more than in this year
but the NHS exists to serve the public
the public does not exist solely to
serve the NHS we never did face the
threat to the health service that the
Labour Left pretended but from small
business owners all the way up to
government workers we do now face it's
counter force X number of days to save
the economy where I are wily New Labour
leader I think I might get working on
that line and deploy it against the
Conservative Party whenever we're next
allowed out to vote that was Douglas
Murray and now professor Paul Dolan a
behavioural scientist at the LSE on what
would have happened if coronavirus
started in Sweden instead schools might
never have closed in the first place had
the coronavirus not studied in China
imagine it's dying in Sweden whoever
responded first was going to set the
tone for the nations that followed when
we are uncertain about what to do we
look to the behavior of others to guide
us imagine walking down a street with a
new restaurant on either side you
remember restaurants right and that you
do not know anything about either of
them one has some customers inside the
other has none assuming you can get a
table you would choose the one with the
people in it because in the absence of
any prior knowledge about the
restaurants other people provide you
with a signal about which to eating but
imagine that the first person walking
down the street had no idea which one to
choose
and did so based on a spurious reason
such as preferring a red door to a
yellow one the restaurant with the red
door would get all the customers while
the one with the yellow door would get
none and this would provide no
information at all about which
restaurant is better now
Sidda China's response to cope at 19
which was to lock down Wuhan it shows
the red door of virus suppression and
school closures over the yellow door of
mitigation and leaving schools open with
the eventual result of herd immunity it
might have done this for spurious
reasons so far as mitigating impacts are
concerned for example because it felt
bad about being responsible for the
virus but just as people follow others
into a restaurant most countries follow
China's lead now there were of course
epidemiologist who advised suppression
because it was expected to result in
fewer deaths from Cobra 19 and so it has
a more rational and substantive basis to
it than choosing a restaurant simply
because of a preference for a red door
over a yellow one but the advice is so
far failed to properly account for
indirect deaths from the policy and the
wider economic and social impacts such
as that on children and the widening
inequality is caused by school closures
to decide which restaurant to go to you
would like advice from experts who
analogous to epidemiologists in a
pandemic know about the calorie content
of the food but you would also like to
know many other things too such as what
the food tastes like how many items are
on the menu and the price of the meal
once short-term deaths from Coburg 19
become the yardstick by which policies
are judged it takes courage to stand out
even if you know you are right let alone
when you can't possibly know for sure
what to do in a world of uncertainty is
so much easier to follow the heard and
risk being one of many who are wrong
than it is to stand out and risk being
the only one who is wrong for that
reason alone and there's techno the
epidemiologist advising the Swedish
government is to be commended it is
important to note that Sweden with its
low population density high number of
single person households and high trust
in government does lend itself to
voluntary social distancing and so in
for social distancing might still have
been the best outcome for sure and
long-term welfare in many countries but
even so if Co bid 19 is started in
Sweden and the country hadn't felt under
any pressure to suppress the virus and
if Technol had set the tone for how best
to respond it is reasonable to suppose
that many more
schools would have remained open
elsewhere elsewhere but not everywhere
suppression policies are generally
preferred to mitigation ones because
they deal more directly with people's
fear of the virus and relatedly because
they signal that we care about the
immediate threat to human life
mitigation policies address the fear of
infection more weakly and lack the power
of a virtue signal suppression policies
might still be more effective of course
but not for these reasons when the UK
went into lockdown the public were more
than ready for it in fact
many were clamoring for it on the basis
that Italy Spain France and Ireland have
shown how much they care about the
immediate mortality risk by imposing
quite stringent restrictions on personal
freedoms the UK government was not
signaling hard enough they cared about
people dying and so when the lockdown
finally came most of the discussion was
around whether the measures were
stringent enough rather than too
stringent in this sense the UK
government initially chose the
restaurant with no one in it but then
ran across the street to the one where
most of its public was seated anyone
brave enough to stand against the heard
the fear factor and the virtue of
signalling to suggest that closing the
schools might be a disproportionate
response was considered a kid to a
genocide or maniac and so we find
ourselves where we are now
schools are closed and the fear of
opening them again looms
disproportionately large in many
people's minds it's time for the
government and the teaching unions to
see past herds fears and virtue to focus
directly on the cost and benefits to the
whole of society from its decisions
based on the balance of evidence from
the full range of experts and accounting
for lifetime inequalities the school
should reopen with a phase return on the
1st of June because the benefits to
children particularly disadvantaged ones
outweigh the small increase in mortality
risks for predominantly older people
that will result measures must be put in
place to ensure they remain open
this would include properly engaging
with and mitigating people's fears and
their desire to virtue signal as well as
more practical
such as social distancing measures and
the appropriate use of PPE that was
Professor Paul Dolan and last anja Watts
ry Brett's a little fish last week's
breaks at negotiations conducted by
videoconference failed to come to an
agreement on fisheries Michel Barnier
the EU negotiator and former French
Fisheries Minister insisted that
continued a European access to British
territorial waters was a prerequisite of
any deal and David Frost his British
counterpart replied that this was
incompatible with our status as an
independent coastal state if there is
going to be no deal as through a result
of fishing as seems increasingly
probable we are going to have a lot more
fish to eat but were also could have to
eat a lot more fish for an island
surrounded by fish Britain has never
really been keen on seafood never an
analysis of skeletons from a Pictish
burial ground in Scotland published a
couple of weeks ago showed that the pics
ain't beef and pork but no fish despite
nipping in what is now the fishing
village of Port mewho Mac they were
quite capable of sailing there are
archaeological remains of a Pictish
naval base at Birkett on the other side
of the moray firth but it seems it just
never occurred to them to catch and eat
fish and it is still true we don't eat
as much fish as most europeans food
historians suggest that this dates from
the Reformation when rules about fasting
were overturned and fish was stigmatized
as Popish flesh but the process in north
of Germany has traditionally more fish
than the Catholic self in Germany as for
most of Europe the closer you are to the
sea the more fish you eat yet weeds
roughly the same amount of fish per
capita as Austria there is a butcher in
my Cornish fishing village which only
survives because of fisherman skippers
fantasy for a week will come in and by a
hundred and fifty pounds worth of steak
for their crew do you never eat the fish
you catch I ask one only if the meat
runs out he says looking horrified my
own theory is that it's the English
language to blame we can eat beef and
pork and on some level pretend it's
nothing to do with cows and pigs with
fish you don't have that almost
plausible denial
ability a John Dory on your plate is
always the same as a John Dory in the
sea and for that the matter little
Johnny Dory in a Julia Donaldson book
that I used to read to my son and which
put us both off the fish for life we can
only seem to eat fish when it's called
fish in fish and chips or fish pie or
fish fingers that is when it's not
recognizable as a fish in the fish
markets of Spain or France you will see
nothing but whole fish for sale but here
in the UK Phil itting is left to the
professionals
indeed the Church of England last year
launched a campaign to outlaw pointed
kitchen knives as a dangerous
anachronism backed by judges and trauma
doctors I read the report and thought
there's a men who've never had to fill
it on mackerel in supermarkets you can
buy fish pie mix a collection of odd
bits of skinless boneless nameless fish
removing the need for any knife at all
when taking us one further removed from
the reality of what we are eating and
reality is I think one of the reasons we
are so scared of fish we can judge beef
and pork by the color of the meat one of
the best ways to check if a fish is
fresh is to look at your size I find it
how to eat bacon if I'd gazed into the
pigs eyes first harder anyway even when
it's cooked provided it's not coated
with batter or breadcrumbs it's obvious
that it's a real animal you're eating
and people in Europe seem better able to
cope with this reality perhaps because
of the language perhaps because they
didn't have an industrial revolution
that took them away from the land as
early as we did I'm not suggesting we
should become totally European and like
the sweets eat stir strumming the
fermented herring that smells so bad the
tins have to be opened underwater all
like the Sicilians Scoob had the gonads
of a sea urchin with a spoon we do not
need the piles of weed the mayor of
French fish markets and so fascinating
the children on holiday or to follow
Latvian Portugal and have a surfeit of
Lamprey's in our supermarkets but it's
hard to understand why we import Cod
from Iceland an export most of our hake
to Spain when hake is a far superior
fish and plentiful in British waters if
you haven't already you should try it
we've got a lot to get through
and that was Angie watts thanks for
listening to this episode of Audie Aires
and thanks to all of you who emailed in
to give us your thoughts that is very
much appreciated and all of them are
read do rate a review spectator radio
and recommend us to your friends and
family see you again next week
The Spectator magazine combines incisive
political analysis with books and arts
reviews of unrivaled Authority try a
month in print and online for free and
for a limited time only get a free
wireless phone charger go to WP tatertot
UK forward slash charger to start today